[Music]
consciousness is one of these great
vexing and confusing words and and
concepts which you know intelligent
people take different positions on it
and could argue about forever my own
perspective on consciousness is rooted
in what you could call a sort of pen
psychism by which I mean the idea that
consciousness is in essence of property
imminent in existence much as space and
time are I mean everything that we see
around us somehow is situated in time
and in space and our space-time
continuum pen psychism is the idea that
everything around us and within us has
some you know element of consciousness
to it also so that it's not really
meaningful to think of you know here's
this non conscious matter and then
there's this thing called consciousness
which is attached to some matter and not
to others now pen psychism to me is not
even that interesting it's almost
obvious it's just the foundation in the
beginning for thinking about
consciousness because then you have
interesting questions like you know why
is the consciousness associate with my
brain so much more you know
self-reflective and you know dynamic and
in some sense is intense then say the
consciousness is associated with my hat
all right I mean that the Hatun it's a
cool high that may be it may be more
conscious than the average hat but I
mean in in the end the brain has these
complex feedback loops the brain can
model itself the brain responds very
differently to slightly different
stimuli coming in and many properties of
the brain seem associated with the you
know the more powerful and dynamic
states of consciousness that it has
relative to other things so if you
accept pen psychism that everything is
imbued some out with an element of
consciousness you know some things can
still be more conscious than others and
some things are differently conscious
there's and then that that's where
things get interesting right when you
talk about AI so I would imagine if I
were able to you know tap a wire into my
brain or Wi-Fi connection into my brain
and why are my brain into your brain
then as I increase the bandwidth of that
wire between my brain in your brain I
would feel your mind they're like on the
fringe of my mind like almost as if we
were fusing into one shared mind or
something and that would be a bit
freakish could be a lot of fun but on
the other hand if I took my mind and
wired it into my hat like I might I
might feel what it is to be a hat but I
would I would imagine whatever
consciousness I feel on the other end of
the wire it's not gonna be quite the
same as melting my mind with the mind of
another human right it's gonna be
melding my mind was something that
doesn't change very much or have much
variety to its to its state on the other
hand what if we think of you know Sophia
version ten point O with her mind
enhanced by the by the singularity net
blockchain based AGI mind cloud right
what if I wire my brain into that does
it feel like wiring my brain into a
human brain does it feel like wiring my
brain into a hat or a breaker or an
earthworm right so these will be very
interesting experiments to do and
they're even scientific in a sense that
that could be audited by the community
like if I wired my brain into my hat and
then I said well I don't feel too much
of the hats consciousness they're just a
little you could wire your brain into
that wire and then like view what is the
fused state of myself in the hat right
or if I wired my brain into super Sophia
and I said wow that's a really intense
state of consciousness now I feel what
it's like to be a robot and it's amazing
you've got sensors all over the globe
that's like it's like a DMT trip to the
tenth power right you could while your
brain into that wire and like looking on
that subjectively
and think wow yeah I can see I can feel
on the fringes of my consciousness like
yeah there's been and some you know
Sophia singularity net super mines which
are fusing together in an intensely
conscious way so that this is what I
think of as second person science right
because it's it's a little different
than just first-person experience that
others can't audit except indirectly
through words or pictures or something
it's also different than typical
third-person science where you concern
with spreadsheets of numbers that are
read out from the dials of experiments
and so forth right it it's sort of
scientific community based auditing of
shared experience among different
entities and I think this is going to
unfold in the next decades as brain
computer interfacing and brain brain
interfacing technology mature beyond
their current significant but still
early stage and this is probably how
we're gonna really crack the nut of
consciousness and see you know in what
sense dispensed psychism makes sense in
what sense or humans differently
conscious than the different types of
computer systems and so forth
[Music]